Buenas tardes aquí en Guatemala en la
capital avanza con normalidad cosa
distinta lo que ocurre en las regiones
le cuento disturbios quemas de papeletas
así como amenazas a miembros de las
juntas receptoras este día de jornada
electoral en Guatemala no ha sido exento
de la atención ha sido un problema para
el tribunal supremo electoral que de
hecho en dos municipios ha tenido que
Cancelar completamente
las elecciones esto por enfrentamientos
entre la fuerza pública y los pobladores
locales y el detonante de estos
disturbios de este resquemor social ha
sido el mismo el posible traslado de
votantes esto se entiende cuando a
ciertos municipios llegan buses con
gente que es ajena a ellos que son
forasteros y los pobladores locales
incluyen presumen que puedan llegar a
ejercer un voto irregular para favorecer
a candidatos asociados con la corrupción
en el municipio de San José del Golfo
por ejemplo los pobladores llegaron al
extremo de amenazar con rociar gasolina
y prender en fuego a estos forasteros
pero no sabían resultó que eran 130
miembros de una junta receptora local
argumento que no caló en ellos porque en
todo caso se enfrentaron contra la
fuerza pública hubo lanzamiento de gases
lacrimógenos y allí las elecciones
fueron completamente canceladas no se
emitió ningún voto y en el municipio de
San Martín Zapotitlán la jornada
transcurrida de manera regular hasta
cierto punto del día cuando otro grupo
de personas arrebató papeletas de
votación en un centro de urnas las apiló
las prendió en fuego también hubo
enfrentamientos Allí se cancelaron
entonces las elecciones a esto se suma
un centenar de denuncias de
irregularidades electorales en la
fiscalía bueno Andrés pues veremos
también los reportes de Los observadores
Internacionales sobre el terreno le pido
pasar otra cuestión y es que hay tres
candidatos que son los más opcionados a
que dos de ellos de hecho pasen una
eventual segunda vuelta pero qué tan a
distintos son sus programas para el país
Comencemos con Sandra Torres que por la
historia política que lleva es quizás la
candidata más reconocida en todos los
rincones de Guatemala su popularidad es
muy probable que la pueda llegar a una
segunda la pueda llevar a una segunda
vuelta presidencial como ya ocurrió en
dos oportunidades anteriores sin embargo
también es la candidata que más antiboto
carga en este país centroamericano ella
promete erradicar la pobreza promete
sendos paquetes de mercados solidarios y
dinero en efectivo para las mujeres
cabezas de familia
por su parte se plantan un espectro de
Centro derecha él es uno donde los
políticos que ha prometido o ha hecho
también unas promesas polémicas como por
ejemplo frenarla migración irregular a
través de prometer 500 500 mil visas de
empleo para guatemaltecos que quieran
irse a los Estados Unidos y para los
mayores de 65 años ha prometido la
jubilación universal
simple y sencillamente presentando su
dpi
zuri Rios que es la hija del dictador
fallecido
Efraín ríos montt se siembra en la
extrema derecha Ella le hace un guiño a
nayib bukele en temas de seguridad
promete meter a todos los delincuentes y
pandilleros a la cárcel Están en contra
del aborto está en contra de la
legalización de las drogas y de esta
manera dos de estos tres candidatos
tendrán o podrán pasar a segunda vuelta
presidencial